- Welcome, everyone.
I'm Hisa.
I have my seat here.
My name is Hisa Kuriyama.
I'm the Director of Humanities
at the Radcliffe Institute.
And I'm so glad to
have Scott here.
He's been my idol
for so many years.
[APPLAUSE]
How many people
is this true for?
Yes.
Is there anybody here who hasn't
read Understanding Comics?
- Well, don't put
them on the spot.
- So if you haven't
read it, this
is the first thing you
should do this evening.
Yeah.
So let me begin with
a question about that.
So Understanding Comics,
probably your most famous book,
right, is a book that makes
a wonderful case for comics
as a art form, as something
we should take seriously.
But it's also sort of a
treatise on communication.
And I want to follow up on
this question of communication.
And I was very impressed by
your talk and the thoughtfulness
not only the content,
but the presentation.
And I'm wondering if
you could say something
about how you think about--
I know you give lectures
at many, many places
and you're an experienced
lecturer and it shows--
how your work in comics and
that sort of comic communication
has influenced the
way you present live
and the differences you see
between live presentation
and, you know,
comic communication?
- Well, you know,
in isolating images
for panels what
you're trying to do
is make sure that you're
siloing each idea that you want
to get across, and
you're presenting only
what's necessary to get
that message across.
We have a minimalist
kind of aesthetic.
Now, there are comics, of
course, that really lard it up,
you know.
And sometimes it can
be enjoyable to see
all the excess detail and
excess unnecessary stuff that's
put in there.
But sort of the default
setting for cartoonists is just
get it done.
And when I'm presenting, one of
the things that I try to keep
close to the notion that, from
the audience's standpoint,
if I don't need to think
it, I don't need to see it.
And I think that
that's a principle
that we violate often, we
being all of society worldwide.
Almost everyone has given
a PowerPoint presentation
at some point.
And there's always
information on the screen,
at any given time,
maybe 80% of that screen
is inactive in the sense that
we're not talking about that
now, but there it is.
And I think that your
eye still drifts up.
It looks at that bulleted list.
And it looks at item number
two, and five, and four,
even though you're talking
about number three.
And we have this notion
that, by adding images,
we're adding value
to a presentation.
But you're beginning at
a deficit in the sense
that, when you give
a presentation,
you have what you have to say.
You have the manner in which
you're going to say it.
You have your vocal inflection.
You have your body language.
You have your enthusiasm
for the subject.
Hopefully, you have
enthusiasm for the subject.
And then what are
you doing first?
You're introducing a
distraction, right?
You're introducing something
that pulls people away
from that.
And so if it's not amplifying
what you have to say
and it's not synchronized
with what you have to say,
it's pulling way.
And I think that's where
a lot of that sleep
inducing cognitive
drag comes from
is the sitting and
waiting for them
to say x when they're still
talking about, you know, y.
Or, I did that, it's
not in the right order.
See, that's going to bug me now.
[LAUGHTER]
Waiting for y-- well,
they're saying x.
That was so unnecessary, Scott.
Just keep on the main road.
But, yeah, it's
what I call the why
is there a llama on the
screen, you know, problem.
And it's just like, we're
getting to the llama,
just give me 10
minutes and the notes.
[LAUGHTER]
- So another
distinctive feature,
very striking feature, that
I'm sure everybody picked up
on in your presentation today
was the use of the pointer.
Not simply to point, right,
but almost like a magic wand,
right?
- OK.
- So that there
seems to be a sense
of something happening live.
And this also happened with
your animations, right?
Something happening live
in what is, in fact,
a prepared presentation,
but it really
enlivens the presentation.
Because one has a sense
of something happening.
- Yeah.
Well, I hope it does.
Ivy makes fun of me for my
attachment to the stick,
but I love my stick.
I love my 7/16 of an inch
in diameter Home Depot
stick that I have to go and
find every time I fly someplace.
[LAUGHTER]
I believe very
strongly there's--
I promise this will
make sense in a sec.
But if you look at the film
Pinocchio, the old Disney
animated film, there's a
character called the Blue Fairy
who shows up at one point.
And the Blue Fairy is rotoscope.
Now, rotoscoping
is where you take
actual live footage of a
person, and you trace over it.
And as soon as she
comes on screen,
you can tell that
she's different.
This can be very distracting.
There have been films in which
rotoscoping was used poorly
in a way that was very
distracting, because all
of a sudden it comes
from another universe.
It comes from another reality.
But in Pinocchio, it works.
Because the blue fairy
is from another reality.
So it's seamless, right?
OK.
I'm getting to it.
I use the stick.
I don't use a laser pointer.
Because I believe that
there are two worlds.
Whenever you get any sort
of PowerPoint presentation,
there are two worlds.
There's the world of the
presenter, the human being
and what they say.
And there's the
world of the images.
You're building bridges.
You're building bridges
between those two things.
That red dot, that damnable
dot, everybody becomes a cat.
[LAUGHTER]
When you see that dot, it
is from another reality.
And what happens,
it foregrounds.
It becomes the
foreground figure.
And everything,
you and the picture
and everything else in the
room, becomes background.
And, whereas, the stick,
following on McLuhan,
is just an extension
of your arm, you know?
You see the stick.
And it's just like, my
arm is not long enough.
My arm-- longer now, right.
You know, with The
Extensions of Man, that idea.
And so I'm building
a bridge there.
Now, when the screen
is low-- this screen
was a little bit high.
I can only reach halfway.
When it's even closer, I
can interact with it more.
But this goes back
to what I was saying
in the talk of this
notion that there are
no neutral visual decisions.
One visual decision that's
been cast as neutral, I think,
throughout the
community of presenters
is the idea that the physical
separation between screen
and speaker is of
no consequence,
that it doesn't transmit
any kind of message.
Well, it does.
It does.
And a close connection
between the two
transmits a very
obvious message once you
see it exploited, which I hope
I was able to do a bit tonight.
- Yeah.
It was a wonderful
demonstration.
So this is an example of your
attention to different media,
right?
So comics traditionally being a
printed form and then a lecture
being a live presentation.
Another thing that I know
you're very interested in
and have worked
a long time on is
digital, the use of the
digital in terms of translation
of comics into digital.
- My Waterloo, yes, my attempts
to bring about a revolution
that's only half finished.
- And, I mean, for
those who haven't
read Reinventing Comics, that's
another work I would recommend.
But I also recommend
going to Scott's site
and seeing his early attempts
with digital presentation
comics.
And I'm wondering if
you could say something
about where you stand
now in terms of,
in your early
writings on comics,
you talk about how
it's important to think
about the new possibilities that
digital storytelling opens up--
not least, the idea
of an extended canvas,
the screen as one long page
rather than simply a series
of reproducing the printed page.
But you also mention
other possibilities
like sound,
interactivity, hyperlinks.
And I'm wondering--
I'm sure you've tried all sorts
of different experiments--
where you stand
on what you think
are the possibilities of digital
that maybe haven't been fully
exploited yet and where
you think maybe still
the paper or the traditional
modes are superior.
- I'll try the 3 minute version.
And then I will close Pandora's
box as furiously as I can.
Because, otherwise,
that'll be the whole day.
Yeah.
It was a full-time obsession of
mine for like 15 years or so.
In fact, I became obsessed with
it right after Understanding
Comics came out.
That was in '93.
And it would be six
months until the web--
- Wow.
- --went mainstream with the
first graphical web browser.
- Wow.
- So it was very early days.
Though, I didn't actually
publish Reinventing Comics
until '99, 2000--
- Yeah.
- --something like that.
But, in short, I
believe that the format
of comics that we
think of as being
part and parcel of the art form,
the idea of blocking things off
into that rectangle
we call the page,
is a technological decision.
It's a decision to fit
it into the rectangle.
By finding a lot of
precursors for sequential art
before print, I was able to
find lots of examples of things
that did not fit into that box.
One of the interesting
things I found
was that they were continuous.
- Yeah.
- It's fascinating.
If you look at all of
these old version--
I'm thinking of certain
very specific Egyptian wall
paintings.
Not hieroglyphics,
that's something else.
But certain Egyptian
wall paintings,
stuff like Trajan's Column,
the Bayeux Tapestry,
the various codices
pre-Columbian picture
manuscripts, all
these things, you
had a single, unbroken reading
line from beginning to end.
The codices, they
were fascinating.
They were accordion folded.
So if you spread
them out, the story
would just go like that all
the way beginning to end.
So the idea was that the
story determined the shape.
And it seemed to me as if, to a
certain degree printed comics,
that technology was
determining the shape.
And I liked the
idea of freeing it.
So many people saw it as
imposing new technology
upon an art form, but I tried
to bring about this awareness
that, no, our art form is
already very much enthralled
to a particular technology.
We're simply maybe releasing
it to take its own shape.
And the idea-- really
just imagine it
here out in pure thin air.
If I said panel one here, panel
two, panel three, panel four,
you start to think about
the possibilities, one
of them being the simple fact
that nearly all panels in print
are the same distance
from one another.
If you look a century
of American comics,
the distance between panels
in 99.9% of the cases
varies between a quarter of
an inch and a half an inch.
That's it.
For any given work, they're
usually identical all the way.
Well, that is the
same frequency.
Think of it as frequency.
Think of the size and shape of
the panel as amplitude, right?
So we have the amplitude
modulation, but not
frequency modulation.
Well, what happens?
If this is beat one,
beat two, beat three,
right, then that would
be boom, boom, boom.
But what if we separate them?
OK.
Now, it's boom, boom, boom.
If time equals space,
then you should
be able to manipulate that.
Frequency modulation, that
was fascinating to me.
But then, of course,
you mentioned
sound and interactivity
and these things.
To me, these were challenges to
the very definition of comics.
And there were some
mutations that I thought
were just an off ramp, right?
It's just like, well, this is
just a want-to-be movie now.
I always point out the Watchmen
motion comic if anyone is--
probably we've all
forgotten that by now.
It's ancient history.
But, you know, there
were some things that
were just trying to be movies.
I wanted to see something
that was actually accentuating
the qualities of comics.
And when you put
a comic sequence,
an entire graphic novel,
all in one massive canvas,
hundreds of panels
all at once, you
are accentuating
the thing that's
unique about this
art form which is
that, unlike prose, unlike
movies, unlike theater,
in comics, it is the
entire past, present,
and future is laid
out all at once.
That's unique.
We're rising above
that landscape of time.
It's not true about almost
any other narrative form.
In almost every other narrative
form, it's always now.
Past is just memory, and
future is just anticipation.
If I go any further, we're lost.
- OK.
- We're lost.
I start to-- you
know, at midnight,
I sprout horns and things.
[LAUGHTER]
- I have tons of
other questions.
But I know that there's
lots of people who
would like to ask questions.
So I'd like to
invite anybody who
would like to ask a question
to come up to the microphone.
And we don't have a huge
amount of time for this.
But there will be a reception
afterwards, which I'm sure--
- Yeah.
- --Scott will be happy to
speak with you individually.
So--
- Absolutely.
- You had said something
during your presentation
that stuck in my head, which was
when you showed the six faces.
And you said that
everyone knows this,
but we don't really teach this.
And I was wondering how it will
change people's perceptions
when they have sort of a
meta-understanding of vision.
It's like, if I go to a
film, I'm not a filmmaker.
I follow the story.
But if I'm a filmmaker, I'm
going to look at the editing.
I'm going to look at the cuts.
I'm going to look at
the camera angles.
And I know people
who go to films
who are schooled that way
who have trouble accepting
the story, because
they're so involved
in the meaning of the
vocabulary of the medium.
So what would happen
if everybody was always
looking at faces and
thinking, oh, I see.
This is a combination of
fear and anger and all that?
- I actually think that it
exists on a slightly different
level from, say, film literacy.
Because literacy-- that's maybe
not the right word, literacy.
But an awareness of the inner
workings of facial expressions,
to me, it's like teaching them
how your heart pumps blood
or how your respiratory
system works or the fact
that the skin is an organ.
These are things that we
believe are absolutely
essential knowledge
that we teach children
somewhere in the lower grades,
you know, maybe around--
well, I'm not
actually sure of this.
I'm very old.
God only knows when they
teach them these days.
But, to me, the notion
that the face is the one
place where muscles go
from your bone to your skin
rather than bone to bone,
where they do not move limbs.
They are an information display.
The fact that you have this
jumbotron of information
for a social species like
us that communicates,
that sends signals silently
through perturbations--
perturbations, that
sounds wrong-- of skin,
is, to me, just basic.
It's like this is what
it is to be alive.
Look at what your body is
doing to send these messages.
To me, that's fundamental.
And I believe it should be
a part of basic education.
And, also, it is so much fun.
I have taught facial
expressions to little kids
and big kids and college
students and adults.
And everybody has such
a magnificent time.
All you have to do is set
them the task of communicating
with another student
a particular emotion,
a particular very
specific emotion, and then
watch if they can get it across
and talk about how it could
have been done differently.
Deconstructing the
muscles of the face--
oh my god, people freak out.
It's so much fun.
It's so much more
fun than chemistry.
And chemistry can be fun.
[LAUGHTER]
- That was actually,
like, really
perfect to move into the
point that I wanted to make
and a question that
I wanted to ask.
When I teach comics, I often
teach it in terms of semiotics
and how we have this shared sort
of connection to everything,
like as a culture.
Can you talk a
little bit about how,
like, when I look at your
book, like I don't see that
in there a lot of the times.
And so I'm like, you know,
there's one thing he left,
you know, like semiotics.
So I talk about that.
Although, well, I
also, like, have
them buy your book and
sort of like read it.
But can you talk a
little bit about how
semiotics sort of
works and the way
you think about these things?
- Well, you know,
in some way, we
could say that Understanding
Comics stumbles backwards
into semiotics to an extent.
It was a very--
I don't want to say naive.
But, well, you know what?
I'll say it.
It was a naive work.
You know, for instance,
Magritte's Pipe shows up
in there, because I had
a professor at Syracuse
who had used Magritte's
Pipe in lectures.
I thought, well, this is good.
This is things
art students know.
I wasn't even thinking
about its origins.
You know, I wasn't--
oh, closure.
I thought closure was
this phenomenon that I
found wider applications for.
I wasn't thinking about its
origin in Gestalt psychology.
I wasn't even aware of it.
In fact, for a while, I thought
I'd been using it incorrectly.
People were telling me, oh
no, that's not we're used.
But they were talking
about literary theory.
And then I had to find out, oh
no, I was using it correctly.
But I was using it this way.
I had to backwards
engineer the whole thing.
It's only really in
the last five years
that I've been
finally getting up
to speed on some of the thinkers
and schools that had indirectly
informed me.
But, you know, much
of Understanding,
I mean, I really have
to say, some of it
I really did kind of
pull out of my ass.
I mean, it was just--
I don't mean that
in a bad way, but I
mean in just a sense
of direct observation,
of like this is how
this makes me feel.
How could that be?
Well, I have just a little bit
of this cognitive equipment,
these tools for thinking that
I got at Syracuse as an art
student.
And now I'm going to see if I
can apply those and extrapolate
from them.
And I came up with things
that others found useful,
you know, like the big
triangle especially.
But it wasn't from a place
of great understanding.
And so, you know,
there are a lot
of writers on this subject
I'm still discovering.
But when you pick a subject like
visual cognition, oh my gosh,
you know?
I'm still working
through that bookshelf.
But I do think that, you know,
the study of signs and symbols
and just the way
that we mentally
reduce the world into signs
and symbols is fascinating.
But it also has a lot of
warring factions, too.
You know, people talking
about the futility of meaning
and sorting through that
can be a real minefield.
So it's a bit of
a rambling answer.
But, yeah, no, there's a
lot missing from the book,
because there was a lot
missing from its author.
[LAUGHTER]
- Would you give me your opinion
on street signs, highway signs?
I mean, they're
extremely mundane.
They're everywhere.
But they're also--
I mean, I had to take a
driving class recently,
so all this kind of
hit me like a truck.
You know, no pun intended.
But they're systematic.
They seem very
intentional, you know,
the way the coordinate
colors, you know, reds.
A stop sign is an octagon, but
a yield is a triangle, you know?
What does that mean, you know?
I mean, it seems as if there
is great thought behind it,
but it's also very mundane.
I mean, our public
life depends on it.
You know, I mean,
don't drive this way,
or you'll hit this person.
Or, you'll hit this
figure if you don't, you
know, drive less than
20 miles an hour.
And the use of colors--
you know, work crews have
orange diagonal stripes.
And this just seems
really artistic
and really wonderful
and meaningful,
and yet it's just very mundane.
And I can't help thinking,
well, all these public employees
probably didn't all go to
design school, you know?
But they might have.
- Well, I think--
- Because it's brilliant I think
- The mundanity doesn't
disturb me so much
as one when signals
are missed, of course.
Because they should be mundane.
They should be background noise.
And I think that
you have to think
of it as a collective
effort, first of all.
Of course, this is the
effort of many thousands
of people over many years.
And so you have
people at the instant
of the creation of certain
types of signs who are thinking
very deeply about it.
And then others later
on will take their work
and maybe misunderstand
it, you know,
misconstrue what the value of
using a particular shape was.
Like the man going
down stairs, he's
a reasonably well-constructed
man going down stairs,
but for a little weird
positioning of the arm.
It does communicate.
But the right to
left thing, you know,
that was just happenstance
that people glommed onto.
I am fascinated by street signs.
There's an episode
of 99% Invisible
with Roman Mars that talks
about a man who was so upset
by a highway sign over
a highway in Los Angeles
that he's snuck there, put
on a workman's uniform,
and put up a better designed
version of it at the risk
to his own life and, quite
frankly, the lives of people
around him just because it just
bothered him, the bad design.
I am bothered when you have
an exit-only lane that's
marked by-- you have, like, a
marker for lane, lane, lane,
and then you have, like,
the exit-only arrow.
But the arrow is equidistant
between the one that
is an exit-only lane and the one
that isn't an exit-only lane.
That's bad and shouldn't happen.
I have a longstanding rant
against the bike lane signs
that have so much space
between the word bike and lane
that they're committing a
kind of proximity infidelity
where they're kind of hitting
on the wheels of the bike,
and they're not showing
their unity as a thought.
But that's just to
make room for the bolt.
But that's another one that
Ivy just tells me to let go.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I think signs-- I
think those things are
absolutely fascinating.
And I think it's long overdue
for a careful evaluation
of which practices work
and which ones don't.
But, yeah, basically,
I think it's
people of goodwill and
intelligence and understanding,
and they are joined by many
people who just aren't really
thinking about it at all, who
were just like given a task
and throw something together
and get on with our lives.
And that's when things go wrong.
- I hope I understood
you correctly.
Because, otherwise, my
question makes little sense.
But you gave a definition
of fishing, I think,
to know what is
where by looking.
Maybe I have to ask
Alexander, Marr, or Aristotle.
But I was wondering why
where, and why not other?
- Oh.
Well, what is where--
yeah.
Locating in space and
identifying what it is
does cover a lot
of ground I think.
- Yeah.
But there's what,
there's how, there's who.
I mean, if you're
a fish and you're
looking for other
things than just where,
just it struck me as
important, but, like, narrowly.
- Well, I would say who is
included in what in the sense
that the parietal lobe
does include things
like the fusiform face area.
So we're using what
in the general sense
of, like, is that my friend Bob
or is it a blender, you know?
And that's happening
in the temporal lobe.
The where in the parietal
lobe, the parietal lobe does
handle location.
But, you know, when you mention,
say, how, something like how,
is it the kind of
inquiry that can
follow on the initial
impulse of vision?
I do think that what and where
covers a huge amount of ground.
But I'm saying really it's
just that that definition,
it arises with Aristotle, but it
comes through Marr's phrasing--
David Marr's phrasing.
But I think that it's remarkable
for its economy of expression
that, in only seven
words, it covers
those four different vital
components of the mind.
Now, of course,
the cerebral cortex
has many thousands of functions,
but vision, definitely,
lives back here.
And the parietal lobe
definitely does handle things
like navigation.
One of the cool things
about the parietal lobe
is that it's monochromatic.
I promise I won't get too
far into this, but it's cool.
So the temporal lobe uses color
to identify what things are.
But the parietal lobe
doesn't really use color.
It's monochromatic.
And so one of the cool
things is that if you
have two colors that are
exactly the same brightness,
they start squirming.
You can't quite
tell where they are.
Their location gets all
messed up and weird.
Sorry, that was so unnecessary.
But I love it.
It's cool.
But, yeah, I think
it's good writing.
Basically, I think I'm very
impressed by Marr's seven
words.
Because it's rare that
seven words can take you
quite so far as I think
those seven words do.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
- You talked a lot about,
like, clarity and images
and how we're surrounded
by a lot of unclear images.
But like some
images do definitely
mean different things
to different people,
especially based off culture,
background, experience.
So I was wondering how that
informs your own image making
or if you ran into any instances
in which you make an image,
and it's, like,
misinterpreted beyond what
you could have imagined.
- I'm sure that
happens all the time.
But, of course, I
wouldn't necessarily
know about it,
because my books get
translated into a lot
of different languages.
And I'm sure people are, like,
scratching their heads at this
or that panel, but they don't
necessarily tell me about it.
But to speak generally, I
mean, you're absolutely right.
And there are some things that
are very culturally determined.
We're always well-off
if we can try
to focus on the things
that are more universal.
But, for instance, the
use of the color red
is a classic one in information
design, the fact that red
often, you know, in the West
will mean danger or, you know,
equivalent urgency,
that sort of thing.
Whereas, it may mean
prosperity in parts of Asia.
So, yeah, there are
definitely issues like that.
I think the quest for a
completely universal lexicon
of visual symbols
is probably futile.
One way or another,
we're going to run up
against those
non-universal differences.
But if we're aware of
them, then at least
we can have means of either
substitution or interpretation
that can help to
ameliorate that.
And also, of course,
many of these things
should be being
produced locally.
You know, much like
government, there
are things that can be done
universally from the top,
from a universal
sort of authority.
And there are things
that maybe should
be done in the much smaller
scale, such as like signage
in a given town.
Oh, can I just say?
My favorite new sign,
speaking of street signs--
somebody on Twitter
showed me this.
It's there is two
paths that diverge.
One is a bike path.
Bike path goes to the right.
The footpath goes to the left.
And there is a sign
for the bike path
with an arrow going that way.
And a sign for the footpath
with the arrow going that way.
And under the arrow is a little
man icon walking this way.
And a little bicycle
driving that way.
[LAUGHTER]
I love it.
- On that note, so let's
all thank Scott McCloud
for a wonderful talk.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]